if x is the median of the seven numbers
listed above which of the following
could be the value of x so the median
means that if we were to put these in
order X would be the middle number we
have seven numbers so it would actually
be the exact middle number if we had an
even number then it would be the middle
two averaged so but let's think about
let's think about this let's order this
and let's put X in the middle of that
order so the smallest number here is
three then we go to four then we go to
four and then the next one let's see we
go to ten so those would be the three
numbers that are less than X then we go
to X and now we go to the three numbers
that are greater than X so then we go to
15 15 and then we go to 18 18 and then
we go to 21 21 so we've now put them all
in order we I knew I could put X here
because X is the median when you put it
in order some middle number notice
there's three numbers larger than it
three numbers less than it so i put x in
the middle and so x has to be some
number between 10 and 15 and including
it could be 10 or 15 but let's see the
choices which of these choices are
between 10 and 15 well fives not it's
not 9s not 14 is we're done 16 is not
its larger than 15 so we're done Xcode
be 14 it could also be 13 it could be 11
it could even be 10 it could be 15 but
out of all of the choices 14 is the only
one that meets our constraints